cross-channel migrants normally operate
in the shadows of night but this is
something profoundly different
dozens of people were told that they're
all iraqi kurds carrying a boat down a
beach in northern france determined to
set off for britain
this was a chaotic caravan of people and
possessions three small children among
them meandering towards shore
and ahead of them
one of the most dangerous journeys
imaginable
these people have paid thousands for
their place on this boat
40 of them clustered onto this one
overloaded vessel
well they've carried this huge boat all
the way down the beach and got it in the
water and over there
is dover and the french police have
watched all of this happen
and haven't lifted a finger to intervene
this was as near as they got maybe 100
meters away incongruously equipped with
riot shields and helmets but not getting
involved
it took 10 minutes to get the engine
started it was not a frenetic process
but then they were gone
chugging off towards the kent coast
and this wasn't even the first packed
boat to leave this beach
one had gone half an hour earlier
similarly laden with people
it can be a time of brutal decisions
some people left behind
and look here the man on the left stands
up and is then pushed into the water and
left to swim back to shore
and all this also ignored by the
watching authorities
we followed both vessels as they try to
cross the channel
the engine is still struggling the
skipper of our boat fears either it will
overheat or the dinghy will capsize
so we've already alerted the french
coast guard to its whereabouts and
condition
but that's not the only problem
the channel is the busiest shipping lane
in the world it's perilous and here's
why
as the boat continues its slow journey
a 400 foot long tanker approaches at
speed
if there's a collision it would be
catastrophic for everyone on the dinghy
the big ship
might not even notice
[Music]
the channel today was busy thanks to
calm waters and fine weather possibly a
final chance for migrants who spent the
summer waiting for an opportunity to
reach the uk
we saw other dingus making the crossing
smaller ones carrying many more people
than they should have done
and also this
a 200 euro inflatable kayak being
paddled across
these men have come from east africa now
with no life jackets they are risking
their lives to get to britain
today they streamed into ports in kent
boat after boat accompanied by border
force lifeboats and coast guard
their journey's over it might have taken
months or even years at great risk and
at hefty cost
but from what we saw today
there's little sign of this flow slowing
or being slowed
adam parsons sky news ambitious in
northern france